fier de représenter en partie ce
rassemblement écologique lui le temps
pour les citations ensemble pour
l'environnement je vous remercie de vous
être déplacés et votez pour nous le 15
mars merci cinquante neuf colistiers
pour cent cinquante propositions pour la
présentation de sa liste dijon
écologiques et solidaires les verts ont
donné la parole à tous des militants
écolos des responsables d'associations
ou de simples citoyens en quête d'une
première expérience politique
bref des profils variés une première
réunion publique
l'occasion pour la tête de liste de
présenter les grandes lignes de son
programme sur la nature en ville donc on
veut chez team en plus de végétalisation
donc dans ce centre ville hyper
minéralisée pour pouvoir revégétaliser
de façon harmonieuse partout au centre
ville mais également hors du centre
ville un programme offensif et critique
à l'endroit de l'équipe sortante dont
stéphanie modde cinquième adjointe au
maire pet toujours partie loin de ces
considérations politiques les militants
et sympathisants semblaient conquis par
les propositions des écologistes zoo
véritable programme comme tous les
partis d'ailleurs et je pense que à
dijon même s'ils ont été apparemment au
conseil municipal
il n'était pas en nombre assez important
pour créer vraiment des émules
il faut en prendre un tournant un virage
radical et c'est un virage politique et
pour l'instant il ya que les écologistes
en parle depuis 40 ans jusqu'ici le
contexte n'était pas assez urgents des
militants des candidats confiant au
lendemain d'un sondage qui place la
liste écolo juste derrière celle du
maire sortant alors l'allié d'hier
sera-t-il celui de demain nous voulons
vraiment pesé nous avons un projet s'il
ya possibilité de travailler sur un
projet commun pourquoi pas tout dépendra
de ce que les électeurs vont mettre dans
l'urne donc je ne peux pas vous affirmer
maintenant ce que nous ferons demain
en tout cas nous avons une politique
nous avons un projet pour dijon et nous
souhaitons le mener au soir du premier
tour ce sont donc les électeurs qui
détermineront si les verts vont rester
dans la cogestion ou devenir une réelle
opposition municipale